so I have something to show you this is
a hammer you probably already know that
a hammer is a hand tool for driving
nails it's mostly just for pounding
stuff it's not really good at anything
else so in a lot of ways a hammer is
better at breaking things than fixing
things don't worry I'm not gonna use a
metaphor the entire talk but I will for
this this is a hammer in CSS it looks
like somebody's selecting an element and
just bludging it with styles and
specificity and important until it looks
right so it has a specificity of 131 if
you count up the IDS the classes and the
elements by comparison a single class is
a specificity of 10 so it kind of looks
like the person who wrote this was
trying to override something this is
another sign that this is a hammer the
use of important whenever you see
important all over the place in one
style block what you're seeing is the
developer screaming at the screen saying
just make it work and of course this all
contributes to a cycle that we find
ourselves in when you look at an
existing style sheet and it feels like
too complicated to understand you end up
writing new styles because you're afraid
you might break something if you modify
CSS or you're not even sure where all
the Styles live and then when you add
CSS you close the loop and you add more
complexity to the style sheet making it
even harder next time so I think most of
us have seen CSS like this judging by
the laughs I think many of us have
written CSS like this and I'll be the
first to tell you that I have written
CSS like this so Who am I you know my
name is Adam Dietrich and I work from
Meetup
what you may not know is that meetup is
13 years old so try to imagine what our
stylesheet has looked like over the
years given the fact that it only seems
to grow and we spend a lot of time
trying to figure out how to keep our CSS
under control and we didn't really make
any progress on this until we started
asking ourselves questions like this why
do we do it in the first place why do we
resort to using CSS as a blunt
instrument when it's an otherwise very
powerful and expressive language
well this is one reason it's definitely
harder to read code than to write it we
know that I think with CSS though it's
especially difficult and that's for a
number of reasons really
you got the quote canonically so this is
a CSS fact it's a rendering blocking
resource these are all the steps the
browser needs to take in order to paint
pixels to the screen so in order to
paint you must first calculate layout
and to calculate layout the browser
needs a render tree the render tree is
constructed using the document object
model and the CSS object model the fun
fact is that the CSS object model cannot
be built until the CSS from the very
first line to the very last line is
completely downloaded in parsed and
that's because of the Cascade you can't
resolve the Cascade until you have all
of the CSS this is fine for a computer a
computer can do this they're good at
this stuff humans not so much it's hard
just by reading the code to understand
which styles are being resolved in the
Cascade where what I'm saying is CSS is
hard even though we have tools to help
us with this stuff when you're reading
the actual code it's hard to understand
what's going on and I think it's
programmers we often focus on technical
problems because that's what we do for a
living we write code we solve code
problems but there are also human
problems involved with maintaining CSS
this is my favorite computer science law
of all time it was written by Melvin
Conway in 1968 it says organizations
which design systems are constrained to
produce designs which are copies of the
communication structures of these
organizations it's a lot to wrap your
head around but it was relevant then and
it's extra relevant now especially with
declarative language being one of the
three main languages of the web so in a
concrete example you often have three
different teams working on different
parts of a website or different parts of
your product they're essentially say
sharing the same stylesheet because it's
the same website and because
communication moves
up and down through this structure very
easily but not laterally very well you
end up in a situation where it's very
easy to create duplication it's not just
easy but it's hard to get away from
creating duplication and when you have
12 different components that sort of do
the same thing but they're not quite the
same which one do you use you know it
they may not match your exact use case
either so it's just easier to write a
new one and of course we also have
deadlines so if you don't have time to
know what is already in the CSS you
don't have time to understand this big
mess that you've made you just add
styles to make it work and every time we
do this we're adding complexity to the
stylesheet
and making it more difficult next time
and this is another big problem we try
to create design systems and style
guides to help solve this problem but
the first time a designer or your design
team hands you something that doesn't
look like the standard components you're
in a pickle you is a difficult situation
because it takes a lot of time to build
consensus to change people's minds to
say no we should change a standard
component no what happens is you just
build a new thing so how do we break the
cycle at Meetup we made it our singular
goal to write less CSS just write less
of it and in order to do that we first
needed to frame the problem correctly we
started thinking about like why did we
get in this mess in the first place
that's where we came up with this idea
of this CSS dead cycle and we started
thinking about the developer experience
at the end of the day it's the developer
who makes the decision to add complexity
to this stylesheet or not and
specifically on that point in which that
decision needs to be made and of course
it's also helpful to reduce design
fragmentation but this is easier said
than done
more on that in a moment so a meetup we
started about two years ago going to a
utility class based approach to styling
things this is a simple example these
are just flush classes they remove space
from an element on whatever given side
not super impressive but it is pretty
useful you don't have to actually open
your
to write CSS to do a very simple thing
in markup but it gets fancier this is a
flexbox abstraction with three classes
where row sets a flex parent and all
flex children get a class of row item
then you can simply declare row items
shrink and that will tell that item to
shrink to the content width here you see
item two is just filling content this is
a more advanced example we also have
responsive classes it follows this
signature at a specific breakpoint
modify a property in some way some
examples at medium display:inline-block
so this is saying when the viewport
reaches the medium breakpoint set the
display this element to inline block
this sets the elements margin to auto
center at the large breakpoint and you
sort of get the idea these classes are
readable they're understandable and most
importantly if you're going back and
you're reading someone else's code
you understand roughly their intention
and this signature this predictable
naming pattern allows us to do a number
of different transforms on different
breakpoints different properties and we
found a lot of benefits in doing this
we've been doing it for a little while
and we found that it provides small
sharp tools each class does one thing
and does it well and it behaves the same
way no matter where you put it in the
document it also allows us to rapidly
prototype it was sort of like an added
bonus that we found out about but you
can assemble a layout 90% there with
just classes alone without having to
write any CSS and of course we're
playing classes to markup instead of
writing CSS so that helps us achieve our
goal of writing less CSS and a
predictable naming pattern in our
classes allows developers this sort of
style by memory yeah the naming pattern
is really close to be e/m except less
underscores because people don't like
typing underscores for some reason but
freezing taste on old classes are a
little bit scary this is an article I
found about a year or two ago by John
Paul assic he was basically summarizing
this methodology of writing CSS it's a
really good article actually but you
know they say don't read
comments well I read the comments and
I'm gonna share some with you
this one says there are too many class
names in one element and the class name
doesn't describe the actual meaning of
the content this person may have the
point it's a little worse from here
though I hope this is a cruel joke that
you're trying to play on people because
this sounds like the worst idea I've
ever seen for CSS you may as well be
writing all your CSS with inline style
tags okay that actually that person has
a point too but this one's my favorite
what's this [ __ ] you write CSS like five
years ago and of course if I had read
this article before I started using
utility classes I probably would have
written a comment like that too so this
is the example given in the article and
by show of hands who feels like a little
bit uncomfortable with this and I am
raising my hand yeah it's like it's a
bummer like it seems messy like you look
at this it does feel like inline Styles
and it seems hard to maintain this
should be a relief to everyone it's a
lot cleaner it feels good and there's
nothing wrong with using CSS like this
it's the way we've done it for a while
the only issue here though is that you
have to write styles to support that and
it's also content derived so each new
piece of content that you have to write
styles for it's a wonder on ratio so you
keep writing CSS and writing CSS and
don't forget if your goal is to write
less CSS try not to write CSS the other
issue that was brought up in the
comments was the idea that this feels
like inline Styles that can be true if
your level of abstraction is too low so
these top examples border top black 4
pixels these are tough to work with
because they name a specific value which
is already a disaster waiting to happen
and beyond that they're too small which
means you need too many of them and if
you have too many of them people aren't
going to use them but the right level of
abstraction is something like text
display 1 or media XL it's not naming a
specific value but it's a concept and
where do these concepts come from well
they come from our design team this is a
list of just text colors but these are
also con
ceps they're not just values like
primary text is a concepts that came
from design and if it makes sense for
design will make sense for engineers
which brings me to my next point it's
really important to foster a good
relationship between design and
engineering and I won't get too much
into this because there's an already
amazing talk from dot CSS 2014 called
bridging the gap between developers and
designers I'm just going to pull out my
two favorite points it's great if design
and engineering can speak the same
language and it helps foster a
relationship if you have a shared sense
of ownership so this is how well this is
just one of the ways that we're trying
to do this at Meetup this is a tool
called style dictionary from Amazon and
it's nothing more than a build tool to
transform JSON into cross-platform
Styles so here's an example going back
to text colors we define our text colors
in a JSON file the values are in RGB a
arrays and then we configure style
dictionary to transform that into
whatever we need the real magic is right
here we define transforms these not only
tell style dictionary how to use the
object structure of the JSON but the
property names and the actual color
values into something usable and here
we're just outputting a SAS file and
this is what it looks like what's great
is that style dictionary is really
extensible so you can do other things
like output those same values in JSON
but what's even better is that you can
use the same tool to produce your
documentation the important thing here
is that when a designer wants to make
sure a color is used correct like
designers wants things to look good in
production they when they use this tool
they have some assurance that it will
become the point of truth for everyone
and I've actually been in meetings where
even project managers and people not in
design or tech at all will talk about
primary text or inverted text and
everybody knows what we're talking about
it becomes a shared communication
between everyone and the other issue
here
is that this is automated as soon as a
designer or an engineer updates our
colors it appears in the documentation
and the documentation never lies to you
and static documentation is just a lie
waiting to happen if you have to
manually update your documentation
chances are somebody's going to forget
at some point and the more it's out of
date the less people trusted the less
people trust it the less everyone is
going to use it and it makes it harder
to solve problems like CSS growing and
growing forever
so to recap if you want to write less
CSS it's important to frame the problem
correctly like recognize why humans are
pretty bad at this a lot of us think
that you know maybe I'm just bad at CSS
maybe my company is bad at CSS or maybe
CSS is just a flood language and we'll
try to code our way around it but there
is a human factor here that you can
solve for if designers and engineers are
speaking the same language and there's a
better relationship between them you can
cut a lot of the duplication issues
before they ever reach your code I
highly recommend styling with utility
classes you have to do what works for
you but I can tell you that it's worked
exceptionally well for meetup and always
automate your documentation from source
all this is important because CSS is
better when you write less of it thank
you
[Applause]